okay welcome everybody to our
q a discussion um i can introduce the
panel
for today um we have
uh
zayadu mandel
who is our lead technical product
specialist
uh in custom uh diagnostics uh based in
maryland uk the usa
we have dominic
site leader for our r d uh based in
dassel
which is our center of excellence for
membrane manufacture
matthew davis who is our custom services
manager in our genomics and diagnostics
business
he's based in cardiff
lee jenkins a senior product manager for
watman diagnostics
based in the sighting cardiff in the uk
and then we have gk eduport who is
product manager for our sample prep in
our genomics and diagnostics solutions
business and just quickly myself
product strategy manager
for the genomics and diagnostic
solutions business also
so we'll go through your questions
uh and we'll put those i'll post those
questions to the panel uh and uh we'll
uh see what uh what answers people will
come up with
hey uh so first question
um uh i think for you tk
uh the question is how is saitifa
preparing for labs moving towards uh
more automation
here's a very good question um
well what i can say is that um
what we're doing uh with magnetic bits
which is one of our strengths so mud
beads they're easily scalable
and they are amenable to automation if
you if you think about different methods
out there in molecular biology and so uh
being the being the must be
expert in the industry we are leveraging
on that expertise on mug beads
to uh provide magnetic beads that are
very robust for several applications uh
so be in genomics
um immunodiagnostic applications as well
um
i would say also to meet with the high
throughput needs
for especially people doing the plague
active purification
we've also been focusing on developing
kits so to say so magnetic bead-based
kits that are more aligned
with automation
than spin column-based method or
precipitation based
method
for example we recently launched the
third extractor cell free dna kit
and that kit is you know it allows for
efficient
recovery of a surface dna
from plasma or serum or urine and it's
mainly used for liquid biology by the
way so if you think about a kit like
that and you compare that to the first
generation uh kit for liquid biopsy um
these were normally your usual steam
columns that had tube extenders to them
and those tube extenders were meant to
help
to to manage the the large volumes that
are required when you're working with
liquid biopsy so with a kit like ours
which is magnet based what we're
providing is a product that provides
that excellent support allows you to
capture yourself so free dna from a
large volume without the need for
additional plastic waste
which is obviously a bottleneck for
automation so that's one thing and and
another one i would like to answer that
is um last year uh we all know about the
pandemic uh and the huge demand for or
testing
um so we again launched the thera
extractor virus pathogen kit and this
kid just like the 93 is optimized for
extracting dna or rna from viruses and
pathogens
so uh kit is currently used globally uh
today
we didn't allow the testing uh code for
south korea or kobit 19 and aside from
people using these kids to meet the high
throughput need we also have an
excellent uh
support of our application specialists
who are always available to provide
support with automation scripts which
are needed to actually um
run
this key so kind of load this key from
an instrument and run it efficiently
that's uh that's uh some of the things
that we're doing towards uh supporting
mountain automation thank you okay so
something automatically helped with the
script
is that is that kind of where you're
going as well
could you say that again please
so is your team also um helping with
scripts so can they help customers to
automate with magnetic beads
oh yeah so what we do yes we do support
with
the scripts and also what we encourage
our customers to do is where they
already have their own script and
an automation specialist we are able to
provide that technical uh understanding
of the chemistry of our kids and
together with our scientists
we're also able to optimize the process
for them so we can provide scripts to
our customers and we can also help them
optimize
the
script that they already have
okay good good
um okay another one in um i think for
probably use uh savador
can the choice of antibody type
canonical antibodies optimus or asthmas
affect the flexibility of choice of
uh nitrocellulose membranes and
ultimately speed of the assay
yeah it's a good question
yes nitrosolus membranes are suitable
for antibody after mars and epimers
after mars are
all epimers are smaller molecules
compared to antibodies due to their
relatively relatively small size
eptomers and epimers can fit into clips
where bulky protein may be affected by
other conditions
due to smaller size of baptomers and
fmrs they may need to attach a larger
protein without whis they may be lost in
the poor matrix of the membrane
but we have a diverse choice of membrane
which is the uh best part and we can
provide different pore sizes to meet
after mars and femers need
one interesting thing
is when antibodies are not a choice
after mars or epimers are better options
but the antibody process is well
established and well known most
scientists can easily follow aftermaths
related protocols are not well
established yet so
they need a special
technical knowledge from the
provider or supplier of optomers fmrs
um so antibodies i know everybody's
familiar with antibodies and an
abdominis may be a little bit
kind of newer do they they come with
their own challenges presumably but
is there is there any kind of
process improvements or changes that you
need to make between
afghanistan
right since
after mars and epimers say femers are
the small peptide 20 amino acid or so
and after mars are like 20 bases
uh nucleic acid
so they are so small
so sometimes it is lost inside the
matrix of the membrane
so if it is uh
attached to a larger proteins that can
be
immobilized on the membrane but this
process is kind of little bit tricky
because epta mercedes is smaller in size
when it is conjugated their
epitope binding site or analyte binding
site might be distorted
but if they can control it if you can
control this
epitope binding site properly uh so this
might be
uh newer options or overcome the
limitations of antibodies when are not
available at all so it's a new
dimension uh to develop the test
okay great great
um and one uh for dominic um so how does
selectivo how can site either uh help me
improve my lateral flow assays
dominic
no perhaps lee could you uh could you
give us uh your thoughts on
on that question lee how can sativa help
improve my lateral flow assays
yeah sure so there's several different
ways we could help people here so the
most obvious is our component supply
so we have a range of different shallows
and glass cyber parts as well as
nitrocellulose products
but also
we have a team of technical experts who
people can reach out to such as sahih in
the us
and people probably know klaus hoffliner
who are familiar with our business in
europe but we also have people in asia
so that's probably another really good
resource people can use
if they want to go above that we have
launched a service within the last 12
months where
we can't support people with a
paid development service for example
we can do small practices of work with
them to help
the development so what i would
encourage people is if they feel they
need help contact one of our team and we
can discuss the different options with
them and work with them decide what the
best approach would be
okay and and
so in terms of that that kind of design
process and just uh just quickly how
does that kind of interaction with
customers is work what does it look like
in in the process of helping with a
lateral flow assay
do we try to be as transparent as
possible and essentially become an
extension of their r d team
so we appreciate that some people
especially if they're newer to
diagnostics may not have the
infrastructure or experience that they
need for a development project
we want to allow our teams to become
part of their business and they can use
us like an r d resource to help you know
accelerate the development of projects
they're working on
okay right
um another one uh perhaps uh again do we
firstly do we have dominic banks dominic
no still some issues with dominic
yeah
okay so so another one maybe lee then
that you can kind of help us with um
what considerations are taken when
assessing what compromises in design and
development process are acceptable
in order to compress the timelines
uh
okay okay sorry and then there are a uh
there are there's a second part which is
are there elements that can be revisited
after the initial product launch so is
that zach are you taking that one yes
yes okay yeah there are two parts of
this question answering to the first
part of your question be sure that the
components such as membrane pads uh and
reasons you are using to develop lateral
flow tests are from reputed supplier for
example switching membrane or antibodies
at later stages should require complete
revalidation of the test system quality
and supply chain issue of any lateral
flow component should be considered
before implementing them in the test
system
uh the second part of your question uh
about elements after launching lateral
flow test
so if your lateral flow test got huge
market for example you need to scale up
the manufacturing process that requires
adequate supply of all components
as well as as well as expanded
manufacturing sites with skilled
employees so these are important comp
uh you should consider
okay and math
david put from the custom side services
side of the genomics business
how do you kind of
work to compress timelines on your side
of the business how do we work with
customers to kind of get them to market
quicker
yeah i think as lee mentioned we we we
work with customers and almost as a as
an extension to their r d team
you know we work really closely with
them in terms of what
what ideally we can do to compress those
timelines from the manufacturing side i
think there are some obviously some key
things that are kind of off limits um
as much as possible i know functionality
and specifications for the end users
something i think will only necessarily
be changed absolutely needed um i think
in terms of what can be revisited after
launch you know things such as packaging
um
things such as that which are not
necessarily key um to the functionality
for the for the end user those are
things i think particularly in the last
12 months you know questions such as
those have really been
um
brought to the fore really in terms of
what the customer absolutely has to have
for this product to work
uh and so we've had a number of
customers who have
you know gone out with um you know the
the functionality of what they were
designed in to do for the product um but
that ultimately you know
would appreciate that there needs to be
a maybe a version two that comes along
later later down the line
um with as i said things such as
packaging labeling um
that can really be um have attention to
and later on ahead of getting anything
to market with the speed that
that the customer needs really
yeah
okay
great
um
next one for you gk so
question is what kind of magnetic bead
is specifically suitable for
sars cop2 rna isolation
i think
for
what's goes to i would say in fact for
any nucleic acid extraction i would say
two magnetic bead type comes to mind
um the first one will be your usual
silica magnetic beast
and the second one would be a carboxyl
magnetic bead
um i mentioned this in my last response
and that's that we are developing
products to support
labs moving to automation and again just
to refer to the previous example i gave
with uh the extractor virus packaging
kit
so this kit is powered by our serous
seal magnetic bit
and uh just to clarify the serous seal
mud bead is a silica-based magnetic bead
we also have uh
you know we also have the ceramide
carboxyl bead
and this bit is well established for
genomics application and
we with kobe 19 uh what we saw is some
of our customers uh you know who are
well familiar with the sarah
max carboxyl these they were using these
d to also isolate uh a statistical rna
and this is well documented in
literatures and uh
even the protocol is available in some
open platform website so in a nutshell
one can actually use the
silica based magnetic bead so our third
ceracil
um
mudbeat and uh second type of beat would
be this ceramic boxer beat
thank you
so i guess the the the silica bead is is
the same as
um
you know the column chemistry
essentially except it's magnetically
uh automatically friendly
how similar is the other chemistry
that's required i know you probably
can't go into the detail of it but to
use carboxyl beads presumably
it isn't too different right
no it's not too different again you have
to consider that the beads on their own
do not uh
the beads on their own are just
providing a solid support right so they
don't work on their own without they you
do require the bottle yeah
now uh people tend to gravitate towards
the silica base speed because like you
mentioned this is you know with the spin
columns this is what people are uh well
familiar with and that works with the
broom chemistry where you use the
carotropic soles
um now if if your hat if i'm had pushed
to make a choice i would always go for
silica because it will give you a little
bit edge in terms of purity but having
said that a carboxyl bead
works excellently well as well and it
will
you know based on boom chemistry so care
traffic salts and it will give you a
good enough purity as well
great thank you
um one for you zahi
i have a problem with the capillary flow
my assay is too fast and i've tried to
add surfactants and blockers for the
membrane but it was not significant
besides the capillary flow of the
membrane is there any factor which could
help to control the capillary speed
yes yeah it's pretty
common issue for most of the developers
there are multiple factors such as sugar
surfactant and blocker content affecting
sample viscosity
however it would be easier for easier to
just swap out to a membrane with a slow
wicking rate
from the same membrane family if they
contain the same composition but the
problem is changing to a slow flow
membrane will change membrane specs that
a customer may not like
if you do not want to change the
membrane specs blocking membrane with
increasing concentration of bsa or other
carrier proteins can definitely slow
down the capillary flow of any kind of
membrane significantly so if you
increase bsa concentration
like two times say one percent to two
percent
the flow will be almost half on the
membrane
so it's quite possible
by blocking you can regulate the flow of
capillary flow
okay and and for my but for me
and maybe for some others can you
explain why what would be too fast and
why is too fast not good
um too fast means the uh depends on the
reaction that will regulate the reaction
kinetics two first means
the antibody antigen has less time to
interact and they will pass from each
other quickly so the sensitivity of the
test will be
less
in case of faster condition but if it is
slow
then it has like longer time kinetic
time for interaction with antibody and
analyte that can produce little bit more
stronger signals
but both condition has some positive
effect and negative effect see when it
takes longer time to flow
so there might produce it might it may
produce some false positive reactions
or the membrane background may not be
clear
uh
just like the first flow membrane
so
it needs some manipulation to control
those as well
okay thanks thanks
um another question number seven so we
do have dominic back on the line
i hope so
should work
yep
yes
okay great uh so dominic question
what are the biggest challenges to scale
up of diagnostic tests
new tooling capacity of existing kits
supply chain issues or something else
it's a very good question it of course
depends on what diagnostic test we're
talking about um we mainly
focus or i will focus now on lateral
flow essays later flow devices
because that's what we face daily
i would say the challenges are various
as the tests in the world are various
everybody has different
problems
um to some
to name maybe some of the biggest
one question is always that you need to
have a sustainable material supply
source
which comes in effect for all components
be it your your plastics your
consumables your membrane but also your
antibodies which need to have a given
purity
and certain volumes that you can rely on
um
maybe speaking more of an r d
perspective it is also essential that
you do not
speed up too quickly you need to freeze
your design you need to understand your
test into every detail before you scale
it up because every
mistake you make in your design and
every
every little gap that you are unsure
about you will see have a
massive impact on once you transfer the
design to production
so make sure that you take your time
to rule out every area that you can
another problem that many
people see many companies see out there
is
that if they transfer from their
research equipment to larger
manufacturing lines that the tests
behave different this is mainly
due to one
simple process um also that is the
drying of the of the lateral flow test
kits
which is essential to its later
performance but
no two equipment behaves the same you
always have slight and subtle
differences so you basically after have
to do a new validation after
transferring you have to re-understand
your test you did laser basics as part
of the design transfer
but now you have to really dig into it
and not push for the market too heavily
because you need to erase all the errors
so
a multi-level approach of problems
but um all of these can be sorted out
okay great so it sounds like um
very deliberate moves very kind of um
planned and kind of cohesive actions
rather than rushing too fast
yes
yeah okay uh great another one if you
don't mind dominic another question
um what is the general timeline
and cost from product concept stage to
kind of manufacturing scale up
very good
we did see what the last year made with
these timelines where companies were
pushing for development of covet 19
lateral flow essays
but typically we are speaking of
two to three years from the start of a
development to
the first test out in the market
this includes roughly a year of
component sampling development design
verification
and then we go into more interesting
stages of regulatory approval
which needs to have certain guidelines
we cannot speed this up too quickly
and then as just explained before
the
also complicated validation and scale up
of the test to manufacturing
so we're typically speaking of two to
three years we saw in the last year that
this can be pushed by massive efforts to
shorter time scales
and as lee jenkins mentioned earlier we
are trying to help everybody with
shortening these development timelines
by bringing in expertise
um but a year is a rough ask already
and i guess kobe's and you know the the
the urgency for getting tests had a huge
impact and almost like
forcing new ways of working
yes yes it did show that
the
interdisciplinary research is becoming
more and more important communication
with
federal agencies is key
we saw that tess got approved quickly to
overcome the pandemic but also a lot of
tests got rejected
just some months later
i think it was a unique situation
i hope we will never see something like
this again but you never know
but communication is key to speed up
your timelines be open be open work
together with your component suppliers
work together with the regulatory
agencies i think these are the best ways
also to speed up the timelines
um the second credit or part of the
question was about the cost for test
development
this is highly dependent if you're
working on sandwich essays or
competitive essays
and
it can range around half a million us
dollars but if you are talking about
multiplexing essays which are basically
two tests in one
one system
it can go up to
even higher numbers
very
different highly depending on your test
system on your used antigens antibodies
which also bring a relevant
portion of the cost to it
okay
and from your side math from the
genomics side what what were your kind
of thoughts
yeah i think on the on the timeline side
as you mentioned um you know covert has
has certainly stretched and and
certainly squashed those um those
timelines significantly i mean we had a
customer that has typically um put
pcr based diagnostic test together in
around
i would say 12 to 18 months for typical
assay types i mean we don't see all of
the development they say because we run
it as a service
but they were able to
you know from first principle based on
an existing assay put together a covid
test and work with us to launch it
within eight weeks
um which was something that we certainly
would uh would never appreciate it uh 18
months ago
so covert has certainly stretched those
i think for us normally um it would
probably be between something of the six
to twelve month mark in terms of uh
alloy authorization i say or um or
conjugation assay based on our magnetic
field technology
um and i think going back to the to the
first point in terms of the challenges
um i would completely agree with dominic
in in terms of spending the time and the
diligence on unlocking down that assay
um with the functionality before moving
through into into scale up and
validation is
certainly benefits you in the long term
you know we've seen customers who have
who have perhaps gone through uh
validation and scale up um a little
sooner than
than there was necessary maybe um
but i've had to revisit that you know in
them you know quite quickly after
product launch um in terms of
redesigning things which is
um always problematic you know when
you're in the manufacturing process and
working at scale it's always problematic
to to go back and then redesign
a functional test specifically there are
some circumstances where you can
as i say change some of the
um
end user workflow
but not necessarily obviously the
functionality and specification of a
when i say that's um that's much more
complicated
okay thanks thanks
um um probably one for chicken and lee
if you could comment as well after gk um
could 903 cars be used for sample
collection in collaboration with uh the
the rna and dna extraction kits
um yes
um yes so with the 903 card actually um
we do have an application notes
on this
and
we were able to collect samples so utm
and even
spots blood samples on them
were able to efficiently extract viral
rna from a 903 card using the extractor
virus pathogen kit
and went ahead to do detection by qpcr
so i have to qpcr um in that a
publication um we we were able to detect
uh down to silver rna down to 50 copies
per microliter
from the universal transport media and
also the blood spots so yes indeed uh
that's possible um and uh the literature
is actually available on our product
page
um so i'd encourage you to go and then
have a a good read because then it's got
more information about the 903 card
stability of this i think up to 14 days
um there's more more good information in
there in the up notes
yeah the only thing i would argue i
guess anyone who's not so familiar with
the 903 protein shaver cards
is that it's a alternative to
liquid plus collection so as opposed to
transporting blood on biles or
using a cold chain it's a very
convenient
technology to use for point of care
plant detection and as chicks added you
know got a great
um combination with the
cereal extractor kit for this um
chronovirus and sales called two virus
detection so it's a nice synergy between
the two
products okay great thank you thanks gk
um and we have
one more question
uh probably for yuzaki uh is it possible
to obtain a highly sensitive and quick
reaction by changing the antibody type
brackets antibody activas or aphamers
rather than the membrane itself
yes yes really very good question
definitely it is possible a different
source of antibody even though it is
monoclonal antibody but if
it's from different source different
animals
uh the affinity to the target analytes
are quite different for example there is
a clinical test
a rabbit using revit monoclonal clone
against pdl one
cancer biomarker the test is in the
market
so that rabbit monoclonal antibody
against pdl on cancer biomarker is like
10 to 20 times more sensitive
than mouse clone
even within the monoclonal antibody
space the sensitivity is like 10 to 20
times
so that means more dilution can be done
cost is way less
like 10 times less than the body cost
and also the process can be quite faster
when antibody is more specific if you
increase a tiny bit of
anti-concentration
quite
short like
15 minutes to three or five minutes or
less
higher affinity against analyte affects
the sensitivity and specificity
specificity so similarly the epimers and
eptomers also can be very specific and
it is
not difficult to
develop
compared to monoclonal antibody and then
selection
so
if
a aftermark and femers are more specific
that way the time can be significantly
shorter as well
okay great thank you so i have no more
questions
um just like to thank the panel so thank
you uh zaki and dominic
matthew chike and lee
for your
uh thoughtful uh answers um and that
concludes the q a
thank you